welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and zack snyder's justice league is
an epic
experiment in restorative justice four
hours of unfiltered snyder spectacle and
mythology that culminate in this
chilling epilogue
an ending i'm gonna try to explain for
you but of course spoiler warning while
you may think you know the story from
the theatrical cut
trust me snyder has created a whole new
narrative
please find the time to watch the full
thing on hbo max
and then you can come back right here if
you need any questions answered
okay among the many differences of the
snyder cut is really how it embraces the
nightmare sequence from batman v
superman the flash's mysterious time
travel cameo in general what snyder
wanted to do to set up the dceu going
forward and in this particular chapter
of it the villain steppenwolf and his
relationship with the true evil of this
dark side so in the movie's climax the
justice league are able to stop the
unity of the three mother boxes
and defeat steppenwolf in the coolest
way possible together
aquaman impales him on his trident black
suited superman punches him toward that
boom tube portal
and diana at the last second comes up
and beheads the [ __ ]
sending his head rolling to the feet of
darkseid who
flanked by decide and grainy goodness
stares down the justice league closes
the portal and now
plans to conquer earth and find that
anti-life equation using the
old ways okay an armada of parademons
and then we move on to this epilogue
sequence narrated by vic's father silas
stone his recorded message
echoing if you think about it the
recorded wisdom left by jor l for his
son
we catch up with all the characters as
they go their separate ways at star labs
ryan choi takes over as director of
nanotechnology setting him up to be the
atom
bruce helps clark get back the kent farm
except
now he adds congratulations by the way
as snyder now makes it so lois is
carrying a
baby basket because earlier in the film
the camera lingered on her pregnancy
test
superman's gonna be a daddy no it's not
gonna go that well for him there's a
quick shot of batman responding the bat
signal from his war machine tank that
was from the frank miller dark knight
returns comic series
and superman tears open the shirt but it
is the black emblem
we see an expanded version of lex luthor
escaping from prison joining forces with
deathstroke promising to form a kind of
injustice league and revealing batman is
bruce wayne
but then we jump ahead to a bleak
post-apocalyptic future dark side's
forces have ravaged the planet this is
exactly bruce's premonition come true
batman has a little motley crew with him
cyborg
wearing a dirty bed sheet the flash
wearing armor
mira and deathstroke on his side but the
true wild card of this bunch
jared leto joker i hate to disappoint
you but he does not say we live in a
society as he did in the trailer but he
does
cackle in taunt batman over losing
people that he loved like his parents
and his adopted son referring to robin
whom joker killed of course
and batman threatens to kill him one day
but joker goes into a very interesting
monologue
you need me to help you undo this world
he created by letting her die
poor lois how she suffered so i often
wonder how many alternate timelines do
you destroy the world because frankly
you don't have the cajones to die
yourself
so as usual i'll be the bigger man a
true spruce
as long as you have this card a truce
but all you have to do is tear it in
half and i'm happy to discuss
why you sent a boy wonder to do a man's
job
and batman responds you know it's funny
how you talk about watching people die
in your arms
because when i held harley quinn and she
was bleeding and dying she begged me
with her last breath that
when i killed you and made no mistake i
will kill you that i would do it slow
and i'm gonna honor that promise batman
takes the joker card
joker looks shook but then says you
almost had me there and then superman
finds them as the heat vision glows in
his eyes but then bruce again
wakes up from this and he's greeted at
his lakeside home by
martian manhunter john johns one of the
members of the justice league seven that
we have been waiting for
the other one the green lantern does
show up in a really dark way
i'll get to him in a second here he is
played by harry lennox aka general
swanwick from batman v superman from man
of steel he was in disguise as this
general the whole time
and he says he wants to help defend
earth alongside the justice league and
snyder closes this with
a touching for autumn his late daughter
and over the credits plays her favorite
song leonard cohen's
this is a beautiful cover of it but
stepping back here to
understand everything we just saw with
joker and batman this future to
understand all fully we gotta go back to
superman's resurrection because
in that moment the ship warned cyborg
not to mix kryptonian tech with this
motherbox tech from the planet
apocalypse and then victor is given this
haunting
vision starting with the unity erupting
blanketing the planet and destroying it
darkseid sitting on his throne diana
wonder woman
dead on a funeral pyre as hippolyta
cries and dark side watches down
victoriously from a ship darkseid
stabs aquaman with his own trident and
uses omega beams to kill other
atlanteans and then
most chillingly black suited superman
cradling the charred remains of
someone we presume to be lois and look
around
this is in the bat cave and we can tell
because that defaced robin suit the
robin killed by joker
clearly in the background there darkseid
places a hand on superman's shoulder and
superman's anguish transforms into a
dark resolve and now superman hovers
over the remains of wayne manor
that nightmare future fully realized the
corpse
of a green lantern is visible looks a
lot like kilowog there and then a joker
card floats past us
torn in half truce broken but before i
continue this video is sponsored by
sheath underwear so sheath boxers are
designed to keep your bits
gently separated for maximum support
take a peek
under the hood teeth has three
individual compartments to keep
everything down there
separate cool and comfortable you got
your mama kangaroo pouch here
but inside that mama kangaroo pouch you
got your little joey sleeping bag and
i'm not calling your joey little maybe
maybe you got a
big joey maybe the size of the joey
doesn't matter fellas anyway a bundle of
cloth for every bit of bundle of you
you know traditional boxer briefs just
throw everything all together like too
many people trying to squeeze into the
backseat of a hatchback
sheath has this modern ergonomic design
intended to prevent skin on skin
contact sheath is like adding a third
row seating to that hatchback so
everybody's got some leg room
and i know you need lots of leg room and
thanks to this kangaroo pouch your joey
down there ain't gonna chafe ain't gonna
need readjusting they were invented by a
us army soldier who came up with the
idea of sheath during his second tour in
iraq where it
is very hot and not conducive for
ventilation for your
junk he invented this underwear to keep
your boys cool and comfortable
so click that link below and use the
code new rockstars at checkout or go to
sheath underwear dot com slash new
rockstars for 20
off and do your boys a favor that's
chief underwear dot com slash new
rockstars or just click the link below
and use the code new rockstars for 20
off
so yes this epilogue is victor's vision
come
true diana is dead aquaman is dead
now meera seeks revenge against darkseid
lois is dead
killed in the bat cave which must have
sent superman
into that downward spiral allowing
darkseid to turn him against the rest of
the justice league
and conquer earth now presumably the
joker must have been involved with
lois's death
he made this happen in the batcave for a
reason to turn superman against batman
how do you do this well
lex and deathstroke know that batman was
bruce wayne
word could have gotten to joker 2 from
there and that is why the joker is the
key to reversing this dark fate
in the vision vic saw that joker card
was torn indicating this must have been
a timeline
where batman broke the truce the joker
went into how he
killed robin with glee and at the end of
that conversation batman killed him in
rage
but what's this joker saying about
alternate timelines well that connects
to barry's time travel cameo in batman v
superman
a moment that bruce brings up in the
snyder cup with diana he said
barry allen was right here and he said
to me lois lane is the key
and diana says lois is the key to
superman's heart whatever but bruce is
like no no i think
it's something more something darker
because folks snyder most dramatically
changed the rules of the dc eu with
barry's newly revealed ability to
reverse time something that is explored
in a fascinating way in the flashpoint
paradox storyline which the upcoming
flash movie is going to be adapting see
back in that resurrection scene
barry uses his speed force to jump start
this process as he does in theatrical
cut but snyder includes a subtle little
line change
barry now adds i don't like to break
this rule but when i approach the speed
of light crazy things happen to time
and then when he speeds down that tunnel
he doesn't just tap that mother box
right as it hits the fluid because yeah
that would be a very difficult thing to
time precisely
he misses the window but he reverses
time
lifting the mother box back to its
precise moment of contact
and then he taps it and this is all to
set up what he does in the final battle
barry again misses his window to zap
cyborg
into those mother boxes so cyborg could
stop the unity barry gets shot
in the side he's super wounded and in
that delay the motherbox has reached
complete unity
and boom the world starts to end but
barry jumps to
action he says i gotta go fast in the
speed of light gotta break this rule
gotta do it now
and he runs and he reverses
the shock wave as he does so he says
make your own future
make your own past it's all right now he
sinks back up to cyborg right before
that unity and he knocks them in to
finish the job
so when we saw barry in batman v
superman yes he was similarly reversing
time he's going back to try to warn
bruce to prevent lois's death and thus
prevent superman from going to the dark
side
of darkseid and that's why barry said am
i too soon
he reversed time way too early to a
point where bruce would have no idea
what he's talking about
and now in this post-apocalyptic future
bruce and barry have
tried to fix all this over and over by
sending barry back
creating the alternate timelines that
joker was talking about but they
probably
failed in all those apparently each
reset also leaves a kind of memory
because joker knows enough to taunt
bruce over these repeated failures
it ultimately sounds like they need a
truce with the joker to spare
lois's life they're talking to the
future joker and trying to learn from
this world-weary joker
what do we need to tell your younger
self to stop him from doing the thing
that's going to destroy the world
and in this moment it sounds like they
found a way in hardly quinn
i think bruce right here found some
leverage i'll save your love if you save
the love of my friend
i gotta say folks this is a dark complex
richly world building ending that snyder
was able to construct here
and i would love to see more if warner
would ever green
light snyder's follow-up but if snyder's
ready to move on hey it does sound like
a lot of this will be explored in the
upcoming flash film
so in a way that snyderverse has been
restored i do plan to do a
scene-by-scene easter egg breakdown of
this whole snyder cut but
i ask you for patience folks this thing
was for hours it's gonna take time for
me to rewatch it to find all the cool
stuff in it so to do this right i need
the whole weekend okay
there's also like the falcon winter
soldier we gotta talk about so please
be patient you can probably expect an
in-depth full movie analysis
next week in the meantime follow me on
instagram and twitter 80avoss follow me
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
everything you love thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you